appreciation in calculus it's just a bad
gradient right so we've just been
looking we've been restricting our
discussion of different kinds of
gradient functions to polynomials and
things and powers right but that's going
to kind of break over we've got three
pushers look at logs Exponential's and
so on and so forth so therefore before
we get on to those and the number of
things you learn have different [ __ ]
just kind of balloons out I want to make
sure we good with these okay what we've
been developing over the last week or so
so let's review so far
you kind of learn our four rules if you
like if the heart of different ship
functions and by the way I'm
differentiation rule is actually the
name of the topic that this comes under
even though I consider this and limits
and calculus is sort of really two parts
of a whole okay so that's why I haven't
made a big deal about this isn't new
topic because it just continues through
so whatever of you I think we said yeah
four rules okay can we remember what
they aren't put them all on face if we
differentiate something with a power on
it okay so you can call this a power
rule or the polymer of your cuz that's
what politics are something say X to the
N can we remember it can we get into our
heads what do we do first
take the power down the power becomes
the coefficient right and then you
reduce the power by one okay now by the
way you've got to do these really really
well that's why I keep on going over and
over everybody's here because towards
the end of the year we're gonna learn
the reverse of this process which is
called integration and if you don't know
these well you're going to be sort of
really in trouble for integration and
you'll also even get the two confused
okay so that's sort of trillion to our
heads then we learnt three other rules
that relate to different kinds of things
different ways that these are combined
okay so we learned the chain rule okay
now I'm gonna try and put these in as
succinct form as I can so if we're
differentiating
one function let's call it f right which
is really a function of another function
so let's call that G so if you like you
would call G your inside function cuts
inside all of those Brack
and if you're outside function right
what do we do
this is chain rule right so if you
remember the acronym we learned for that
was price okay the most important of
others be the two middle ones right
inside function you differentiate that
first so you'll end up with G - okay and
then you differentiate the outside which
is F - okay so like I said we've
mentioned this before that this whole -
notation thing we generally try to avoid
it except but with none of these rules
because they're always going to look the
same each time
okay so that was chain rule then what
was the next one product rule thank you
okay so it's one way differentiating
something which is one function multiply
it by another and we call them U and V
so this is what I've got
by the way here on the left hand side
I'm putting my U of X and V of X just to
remind you that you would be aren't just
variables they're actually functions all
bags sir do you remember what was the
yeah okay yeah it's a it's a boom right
I seriously like I made this up but this
one is in textbooks everywhere okay you
can go check out yeah it's for real
okay sometimes they put it backwards
they have a it's confusing because the
next rule is question and I believe that
very last thing we did was how we derive
this result really question rule is just
a special version of product rule okay
so for instance when you've got you on X
divided by V of X what do we get well
the top the numerator looks very much
the same the difference is there's a
negative able to be in the middle okay
so you still got a rule of sorts on the
top and then you're dividing by v square
okay good all right so that's what you
learnt so far okay now I'm learning
these by the way is not enough because
so far giving you exercise
for each one but because it's an
exercise specifically devoted to you for
instance learning the product rule you
sort of automatically your mind is on
autopilot because like all of these
questions have to do with pronto so
you're automatically going there in
reality and in like exams and that kind
of thing they'll give you a question and
it doesn't tell you nice and neatly use
this method we're using that method
right so you have to discern okay now
you might think well isn't it obvious
what you've got a product issue this
approach with your question you should
use the question rule well not so fast
so let me give you two examples
suppose I asked you to differentiate
this okay this is a nice easy example on
the face of it it looks like a question
so you would use the question rule right
now you can't do you get the right
result but a way better approach to this
is to say well look on the demo here I
can divide both of these terms by that
denominator right so this is really the
same as asking x squared on X is just X
and 1 on X is 1 over the X okay and that
is tons easier different Shin right
because that's just 1 and this power
comes out the front and then you reduce
the power by one sweat you get that you
know you can see you know boom over B
squared so this will be there's the V
squared appearing right it'll get the
same result but a question will be much
much longer okay and in the same way if
I said well okay differentiate something
like this again it's a it's a question
right but what's better way to approach
it would be it takers this is chain rule
why it's both of them but it's better to
consider as 2x minus 1 to the minus 2
okay so how would you destroy derivative
all right so what would you do here
what's chain rule would you go for the
inside okay so it'll be 3 times 2
there's the inside and then you bring
the power down and then you reduce the
power by one
okay so what's that 3 by 4 is minus
to X minus 1 cubed okay now I'm not
going to go all the way but just to
demonstrate how a name it would be what
would happen if we didn't rewrite it and
then do it as chain rule if we thought
of this as a U and V okay well how's it
gonna start it's gonna be 2 X minus 1
squared that's a V then you - which is 0
minus u V - so you're doing chain rule
again to put 2 X minus 1 all over 2 X
minus 1 to the 4 right
actually this turns out to be not that
bad because of this zero but number 1 it
takes longer just to write this down
like at the time it took to write this
down I could have solved it already and
number 2 because there are so many extra
bits it's a far more error-prone method
okay
so it's a bit like sort of pouring like
boiling water with your hunker hand
right I mean like it'll work but you're
sort of asking yourself to get burned
right I'm so in general when it comes to
looking at these methods and picking the
right one
almost always it means avoid the
question rule like the plague that's the
main thing together
okay but this year I'm going to give you
is sort of a mixed sheet so let's you
look at the questions and then pick
which method or which combination of
methods of use okay is there any
questions